how do we do this but this is not
working
Elliot Elliot Elliot how's it going I'm
iffy and this is yeah and I'm her dad
Teddy and I'm gonna try to recreate her
favorite princesses hairstyle I just
woke up so it's a perfect time to do
both of our hairs probably just do her
as though not mine
it's gonna be a challenge
yeah oh I shall win who's your favorite
princess ooh what do you like Elsa is
she cool
can you sing let it go you don't have to
sing it who's your favorite princess
iris princess Belle about for today we
do Belle are you excited for me to do
your hair like Elsa yeah all right well
without further ado I guess we'll just
jump right into it right be kind of
break it down this hair
so for Belle's her style I do notice
that it involves some curling of the
hair and it has a nice bun on top I'm
not great with buns I'm better with
ponytails but I think the curls can be
achievable right mama
yeah so we gotta get them now - great
how about this how about I start off by
just kind of straighten out your hair I
feel like we need to detangle this bad
boy a little bit how's that sound
no thank you
your favorite part of frozen there yes
wise wise I'll see your face
I think we're good to go let's go on to
the next step
French braid tutorial so what I'm gonna
do now is attempt my curls I'm gonna
start should i be partying this in
sections we have to rush all your hair
to one side she did this in like two
seconds just before just brush it one
two three four five okay okay than that
bad bad nice little curl we just need
one solid braid they're all gonna come
together
thank you you know what I feel like my
confidence level is going up and up
after every curl we do okay try and eat
a rough just need to get your hair
detangled so we can do the braid Elsa
what the braid like Elsa to look so mad
well I'll do it
maybe you do and maybe I'm doing the
wrong hairstyle I hope I'm not doing the
wrong hairstyle how do you think your
hair's looking pretty scary
you think they'll look scary
[Music]
maybe after we do our hair stop may we
have some ice cream
that sounds good okay
there's a little button one time daddy
get me dead get the fourth piece which
I'm assuming is going to be this is not
working
oh yeah hell yeah it's not working hold
on I'm gonna Google how to make a bun
into the dangerous territory over here
come together they worked against me
they're working against me
oh okay okay so we're gonna need a
couple bobby pins which we have okay sir
the seat I'm just going to see it
created a fifth string Bobby do you know
how bobby pin yes I like this because
you can't see what's going on so it's
building up suspense over here sometimes
you're gonna do last-minute edits he's
blue because you know else about the
blue dress we have our bun okay now
let's have a ribbon huh almost done
let's see master ties the hairstyle all
together what do you think yes I agree
let's do the reveal please stand up so
you can see it you look beautiful
yes you do you really like it you like
it what you look like Princess Elsa oh
you want to change your dress okay
okay now do you look like Elsa oh you
want to spin around to do do your magic
it because just a great experience its
I'm glad I kind of like take this as a
challenge rather than just doing your
typical ponytail yeah we did it alright
alright say bye mommy
[Music]